hey I'm an award-winning Scrimshander be
I'm a moderately influential warlord hmm
see I write personality quizzes for
magazines okay well your hands are far
too docket for real scrimshaw work hey
who's this oh that's butthole I found
him out in the alley a couple years ago
why didn't even butthole oh cuz of this
oh yeah good name totally fits you know
one of those useless machines he used to
make is called an MRI and afterward any
of those left the doctor's would have
been able to run the cyst in my wife's
brain before she died and said
afterwards then she'd have been the one
sitting there listening to this daddy
pig hi let's just take this slow
too much not too much and here to shed a
little light on the subject for us is a
very special guest please welcome mr.
Peeta Mellark Peter a lot of people feel
as though they are in the dark yeah I
know how they think now so set the stage
for us talk us through what really
happened on that final and controversial
night well first off you have to have to
understand that when you're in the games
you only get one wish it's very costly